box-office success for a Marvel film is
no big surprise but the numbers for
spider-man far from home are well above
even the hefty expectations that have
been set for Spidey second solo swing
through the Marvel Cinematic Universe
here are some reasons why it's soared
and if you haven't seen it yet here's
your warning spoilers ahead far from
home bust in what you might call an
endgame aura coming just two short
months after the Avengers climactic time
heights broke the opening weekend record
to the tune of 1.2 billion dollars far
from home promise to serve as an
epilogue to 11 years of Marvel films a
preview are far from home was added to
the endgame we release in the place of
an after credits scene the rerelease
effectively stirred the waters
bringing Marvel back into the forefront
of moviegoers Minds teasing that far
from home promised some juicy answers to
those lingering endgame mysteries
endgame juggled a lot of different
characters and storylines is that
everyone you wanted more so a relatively
low-key film like far from home helped
answer some basic questions it showed
what life was like in the aftermath of
the bleb the characters turn for the
second snap that brought everyone back
in endgame it addressed the age
differences caused by the five-year gap
and showed how the world was handling
the loss of Tony Stark people quite
simply love Peter Parker the webhead is
one of the most popular super heroes of
all time having served as Marvel Comics
flagship character for more than 50
years and holding down his own movie
franchises for nearly 20 Andrew Garfield
that a compelling if sobering Jabez
Peter Parker in his pair of amazing
spider-man films and the web slinging
Wonder Boy Tobey Maguire will always
hold a nostalgic place for fans but ever
since he first appeared in Captain
America Civil War Tom Holland has
clearly created one of the most popular
versions of spider-man to date he just
seems to have a charisma people can't
get enough of spider-man far from home
was released on a Tuesday which gave it
a lengthy 6 day opening weekend in the
midst of a busy summer movie season the
release date had originally been Friday
July 5th but Sony made the wise decision
to move that data to before the
Independence Day holiday the move was
meant to avoid any negative impact from
the movie debuting around a holiday an
arrangement which can cause a dip in
ticket sales the shift to Tuesday helped
the movie gain momentum heading into the
fourth of July and they've paid off in
spades
not only did the movie hits a home run
at the box office but it broke both
Tuesday and Wednesday ticket sales
records even beating out endgame in the
process
far from home surfed as a finale the
only two MCU phase-three but also to the
infinity saga as a whole marvel
President Kevin Feige explained why
Spidey's story needed to be the bookend
that showed what came after Tony Stark's
death in endgame the relationship
between Peter Parker and Tony Stark is
so special that we needed to see how the
spider-man step out of the shadow of his
mentor Tony Stark far from home wasn't
just a follow-up to endgame it was
literally the final chapter in a 22 film
story making it a must-see experience
the film is also the last MCU movie
scheduled for release for nearly 10
months so MCU fans looking for that
superhero fix knew that this was their
last chance to get one for a bit from
Marvel Studios at least brought to life
by Jake Gyllenhaal Mysterio is a
spectacular combination of a compelling
background sinister motives and twisted
logic he's a villain with depth and
motivation that resonates with the
viewers in part because he's so
sympathetic and likable in the first
half of the movie even the trailer spun
him as a hero from another dimension a
sort of second Iron Man backs evil
motives weren't a sure bet going into
the film after all just a few months
before Marvel had poured a 180 with the
scrolls in Captain Marvel turning the
classic comic book villains and the
tragic protagonists on the screen my
people lived as refugees
on tour for homeless ever since we
resisted Kree rule and they destroyed
our Welbeck ultimately showed his true
colors his loyalties were an open
question and one that likely pushed many
viewers to head to theaters looking for
an answer it was widely reported that
the late Stan Lee's last cameo would
come an endgame that turned out to be
true but that didn't mean other cameos
will be left by the wayside and far from
home a key question for many fans was
just who would be showing up in the film
given his appearance and the trailers
Nick Fury's involvement was a given but
one surprises I hear Maria he'll turn
out to be Scrolls in the skies while the
real fury is taking a vacation with Ben
Mendelsohn and Sharon Flynn reprising
their roles as Talos and Sauron from
Captain Marvel in another interesting
twist Peter Billingsley reprises his
role as William Gynt areva the scientist
confronted by Obadiah Stane in Iron Man
and of course the best surprise of all
have to be JK Simmons returned to his
role as Jay jonah Jameson during the
mid-credits scene you don't trust
anybody that's your problem
I trust my barber fans knew that the
creators of Marvel wouldn't let them
the Cameo departments and sure enough
they came through with flying colors far
from home clearly functioned as a
capstone for the infinity saga but it
also promised the liver a taste of what
was to come next in the MCU how would it
continue without Tony Stark and Steve
Rogers at the helm what Peter Parker end
up stepping into iron man's boots and
how would the world be any difference or
even make sense after the snap or the
blip that followed what about the
multiverse snap tore a hole in our
dimension the desire for answers to all
these questions along with a glimpse at
how Marvel was setting things up for
phase 4 but certainly on the minds of
many fans as they bought their tickets
more than once for some it seems check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
MCU
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]